it is a journey through remote towns and
villages to get close enough to see the
power plants which is now under russian
military control
from territory still held by ukrainian
forces major valentin yermalenko
points out where the fighting has been
most intense
the closeness of this war to these
nuclear reactors has caused warnings of
disaster and international condemnation
on the horizon steam hangs over the
plant a sign that it is still
functioning
but the haze over the buildings makes it
difficult to see the damage where the
russian shelling started fires
the nuclear power plant is just over
there across the dinipro river it's
about four miles from our position here
now this is close as we can get safely
we've been brought here by a military
escort
we've been asked to keep low because
there is the danger
of incoming fire now there is still
fighting going on to the right of the
plant
and if anything was to happen to it
well it would add a really worrying
dimension to this conflict it would have
implications not just for ukraine
but for all of europe
these pictures show flares lighting up
the plants as the russians launched
their assault
the cctv network recorded as the tanks
rolled in
grainy pictures but it's clear just how
dangerous this situation could become
foreign
russia claims it's only firing at
military targets but this school in
sotomir tells another story
so many families are being displaced by
this war
these were residential buildings in the
city of chernhiv
but look at them now
as the emergency services try to put out
the flames
residents don't know where to turn
[Music]
and as the russian invasion moves
further into the country more and more
people are fleeing
this queue at a checkpoint just outside
dunipro goes on for miles and miles
many more families will be forced to run
before this conflict is over
alex rossi sky news
zaparizia